in this series i'm gonna surprise you
i'm gonna strip away all the complexity
and hard craft and teach you how to cook
amazing food standing on your head that
is amazing incredibly tender from the
kitchen novice to the budding chef i'm
gonna give you the confidence the
recipes and the insider knowledge to
make you a much better cook slice around
wasting nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
i made my name cooking in some of the
world's most demanding kitchens
it's nice to make
in my restaurants i expect perfection
every plate has to be worthy of a
michelin star and every time you make
them taste it as well every day it
changes
now i'm going to show you some simple
and accessible recipes for fantastic
food that you can easily cook at home
incredible
i'll be holding you by the hand just
getting better and better and better
teaching you everything from incredible
stress-free dishes real fast food and my
ultimate feast recipes this is the only
cookery course you'll ever need
welcome to my ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on
right this is my ultimate food on a
budget
as a chef i know it's not what you spend
on ingredients but results on the plate
that count
using cheap cuts and leftovers and
working them hard in the kitchen gives
you food and a budget that tastes a
million bucks
and i'm gonna show you how
first up my flavor-packed lamb with
fried bread
whether i'm cooking high-end dishes or
rustic dishes trust me it all has to be
impressive so this lamb dish proves that
you don't have to spend a fortune to
create delicious food
first off put the pan on
this is a lamb steak and it's cut just
above the leg just here because you can
see that delicious bone running through
the center and that's full of marrow so
that just gives the lamb a nice added
sweet flavor
just take your knife cut through each
end this stops the
lamb steak from buckling so therefore it
cooks evenly and colors beautifully salt
and pepper
lamb needs quite a lot of help with the
pepper so
be quite generous with the pepper
and just pat that down
the pan is just under smoke on the
outside now put the oil in get that pan
really nice and hot because this is a
cheap cut so
i'm depending on the color of the lamb
steak to really sort of impart a lot of
flavor
that's the noise you want to hear you
can't hear that noise don't drop the
steak in
put a little bit of garlic in there not
chopped garlic just whole cloves the
garlic lightly crushed
don't even waste time peeling them in
tongs lift up
that bit of fat around the back that's
the top of the leg
tilt the pan and let all that fat render
rendering is a chef's term that means
melting the fat it works brilliantly
when you're cooking a rib eye as well
cut it
that over there beautiful
now it looks like an expensive cut and
we've got that nice even sear
all over
as it's cooking just tilt the pan
and vase
and basting the lamb steak just means
you're sort of adding all that nice
scented
garlic olive oil back into the lamb
useful
now take the lamb out let the lamb rest
[Music]
now
for the perfect rustic crouton so this
bread's quite firm a couple of days old
just slice it straight down the center
dice it up
put it into a bowl
season it beautifully
[Music]
from there i'm gonna add some milk
sounds strange adding milk to crouton
but it just gives it that nice rich
creamy texture
and just let that milk sort of absorb
into the bread while that's soaking i'm
gonna make the dressing go back to that
initial garlic that was in the pan
look at that beautiful into the pest and
water anchovies
anchovies go brilliantly well with lamb
i want that nice salty vinegary flavor
and a bit of kick some capers
the little baby cats very sweet
now
just pound that to a nice paste
that smells incredible
next some dijon mustard
a nice teaspoon and a half in a little
bit of red wine vinegar two tablespoons
and then our extra virgin olive oil
now
it's got that heat in there i've got a
nice roasted garlic a real hearty chunky
vinaigrette that sort of seeps into that
lamb
some fresh parsley
crunch up the parsley
delicious flavor parsley in
nice
now get your pan hot for the croutons
olive oil in the pan
grab the croutons and squeeze all that
excess milk out not too hard i don't
want them dry
and in
and then just fry them
and the milk inside these croutons
give it a nice spongy creamy delicious
flavor
that's the color i want
nice
now take them out and lightly drain them
a little bit of kitchen roll onto the
board out
[Music]
plate them just take this amazing
vinaigrette
and spread it get those croutons
listen to them
like little boulders hitting the play
the lamb
sit that on
next one
on
the rest of the croutons
on now use all those little bits
and my chef in paris would kill me right
now if you saw me using those because
they're the ugly scraps that customers
should never see but but they're the
best bits
croutons on
and then just
drop that sauce on all those little bits
of the lamb
and there that is a perfect way
of taking a cheap cut
is the premier league of dishes
stunning food doesn't have to be
complicated keeping it simple produces
amazing results and keeps costs down
here are three more great easy dishes
that don't cost the earth but taste
absolutely incredible
starting with roasted mackerel with
garlic and paprika
[Music]
first make a spicy paste by crushing
garlic in a pestle and mortar
along with paprika
sea salt
and olive oil
spoon the paste onto phillips of
mackerel a great inexpensive oily fish
that's really healthy and leaf to
marinade
when ready to eat put the mackerel
fillets on a baking tray skin side up
season and roast in a hot oven
next make a tangy potato salad
for the dressing mix dijon mustard
white wine vinegar
olive oil
and saffron
[Music]
and whisk until blended
boil new potatoes in salted water
drain and lightly crush
add sliced spring onion and spoon in the
vinaigrette
[Applause]
to serve top the potato salad with the
roasted mackerel and drizzle with more
vinaigrette
[Music]
a healthy meal that makes the most of
cheap but delicious fish stunning
roasted mackerel with garlic and paprika
[Music]
my next brilliant budget dish
is pork and prawn balls in aromatic
broth
[Music]
for the pork and porn balls in a bowl
add pork mince
then add finely chopped prawns
[Music]
diced ginger
and chopped chives
season
and roll into ping pong size balls
[Music]
for the broth heat fresh stock
and add star anise
oyster sauce
soy sauce
and sliced ginger
gently simmer
fry the pork and prawn balls in a pan
until golden
then transfer to the bubbling broth
add handfuls of spinach
then serve
topped with finely sliced spring onions
a gorgeous healthy dish that uses great
value ingredients with amazing results
pork and prawn balls in aromatic broth
ready to eat in under 20 minutes
an incredibly simple recipe that's
perfect for using up leftovers easy
arancini delicious golden rice balls
[Music]
first chop mozzarella into small cubes
then take handfuls of leftover risotto
add a cube of mozzarella and fold into a
ball around the cheese
this dish is perfect with leftover
mushroom risotto but it's great with any
risotto
for the coating prep three bowls one
with flour one with breadcrumbs and one
with beaten egg
dip each arentini first into the flour
then the egg wash and finally the
breadcrumbs
then in a pan
heat the olive oil and fry the arancini
until golden brown
[Music]
drain and serve simply with lemon
[Music]
easy arancini a delicious tempting treat
that's great for leftovers and cooks in
under 10 minutes
three quick and easy recipes that give
maximum flavor for minimum cost
fantastic dishes that prove you don't
have to spend a fortune to eat amazing
food at home nice
[Music]
five more of my 100 tips they'll make
cooking in the kitchen easier
first up
a great cheap staple how to cook the
perfect rice basmati rice the king of
all rice is light fluffy delicious and
i'm going to show you how to cook it
perfectly
now
start off with
400 grams of rice
rice in
spot on
so what i'm going to do now is just
rinse off the dust and the starch
cold water always
and just rinse
the rice
that stops the rice from becoming clumpy
in the pan and allows it to become
really nice light and fluffy once it's
cooked
rice
into the pan now to make a plain fluffy
rice exciting we're going to infuse it
three cardamom pods
and just get the pods and just pierce
them so it allows all that flavor to
come out
cardamom pods
and then
star anise now these are beautiful whole
star anise
it makes it really nice and fragrant
salt and pepper a lot easier to season
the rice now
than it is once it's cooked you start to
break it up when you season once it's
cooked now it's basically
one part rice to one and a half part
water
600 mils always start off in cold water
cold water in
onto the gas
lid on
bring it up to the ball as quick as
possible and turn it down and let it
simmer for 8 to 10 minutes and that's
the secret behind cooking great rice
allow it to steam as it's cooking
do not lift that lid up
lid off
[Music]
it smells aromatic basically all the
water's absorbed the rice has doubled in
size and is nice and light and fluffy
take the staranise out
the cardamom pods they all should have
risen to the top
pods out
take your fork
fluff it through
basically just sort of starts to open
everything back up
once you've forked it through it becomes
really nice and light and fluffy
and there
that is perfectly cooked rice
always make the most of your leftovers
use last night's rice in stir fries
scrambled up with eggs or it's simple to
make a delicious fresh salad remember a
good cook wastes nothing
a great tip for stopping potatoes apples
and avocados from going brown wing cut
simply cover with water and add a
squeeze of lemon the acidity stops the
flesh from oxidizing which is what
causes the color to change
herbs are great for adding flavor
without spending a fortune to keep them
at their best simply place them in a
glass of water and they'll stay fresh
for up to a week
[Music]
and if you've got extra herbs left over
save and waste by making an amazing
flavoured oil place wash and dried stems
in a bottle
cover with warmed olive oil
then seal and leave to infuse great for
salads pastas and drizzling on veg
[Music]
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on later i'll
be showing you an incredible spicy
sausage rice that cost next to nothing
bulky delicious and incredibly robust
but first when you're cooking on a
budget you can still eat fantastic meats
just make sure you're getting the most
for your money next up my shopping guide
to buying the best hams salamis and
sausages
these fine italian meats are packed with
flavour and a little goes a long way
and nobody knows that better than deli
maestro antonio sakamani i born in italy
and i start eating italian food
and i love it i want to change it for
nothing else
that's why i'm
fat
he's been selling delicious cured meats
in the heart of london soho for more
than 35 years
this is
the best prosciutto they come from italy
this is curing parma because it's parma
ham
divine people love it and it's wonderful
the fat is good because you make the
meat sweet
they should be cut thin like this there
is more flavor you can eat with melon
with figs with pears with everything any
sweet fruit is good
it's wonderful you really enjoy when you
start eating you can stop wonderful this
is called prisaola it's a hair cured
beef
it comes from north italy valtelina
it's so different from pork
there's no fat at all it should be no
fun otherwise it tastes greasy it's good
when it's very dry and you slice it
thinner you just eat it like that or you
can eat with a bit of rocket or you save
some parmesan on top
i love it a bit of lemon if you like or
olive oil it's delicious
this is called felino for me is the best
salami take the name of our little place
near parma and other is country salami
very nice it's one of my favorite
because it's not too spicy just meat
flavor just salt and pepper
i love it i can't resist
when i take some meat home
i don't eat nothing else especially in
the evening just meat with a
melon or
fish or whatever
a few slices of bread
a couple glasses of wine that's my meal
you don't need nothing else you know you
you happy
antonio's right incredible italian hams
and salamis are fantastic in simple
salads sandwiches or even eaten by
themselves and you don't need much to
make an impression
there's an amazing selection of
delicious meats from around the world
that are great to use in the kitchen
another simple meaty staple that's
perfect for quick easy suppers with a
difference are the exotic regional
speciality sausages that have such
distinctive tastes and are a million
miles from the great british banger here
are four of my favorites that are
definitely worth your money chirizo from
spain these have an incredibly deep red
color are full of smoky spiced paprika
and are great for stuffing stews and
paellas
merguez from north africa made from beef
and mutton these cook super fast because
of the long and thin shape and can be
used in tagines or served with couscous
fennel sausages from italy made from
pork and packed with sweet aniseed
flavor fennel seeds these are perfect
with pasta or as a topping on a pizza
finally jerk sausages from jamaica full
of blow your head off scotch bonnet
chilis these are super spicy and great
in tangy casseroles or simply sauteed
with onions and garlic be adventurous
with your sausages learn about the
different flavors and you'll soon be
using them to add extra flavor with ease
for dishes that always pack a punch
without costing a fortune simple and
cheap delicious ingredients like
sausages are great and you don't need a
lot of them to get stunning dishes that
taste incredible so spend your money
wisely and you can have amazing midweek
meals that don't cost the earth
my next recipe is all about great
flavors and it's as cheap and easy to
make
as it is delicious
spicy sausage rice
whatever you're cooking the secret to
making great food is to ensure you're
locking every last ounce of flavour in
that pan and this spicy sausage rice
does exactly that
take these spicy sausages and pierce
that skin because i want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of this
casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas
bread onion less acidic than a big white
spanish onion and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because i want all that fat coming
out the sausages to sort of really help
flavor the onions onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to six minutes in the pan so you
can really start to caramelize them
my mouth and my pepper
slice around
wasting nothing
i want to see that sort of
little core those pips in the center no
fine diced pepper the rice is going to
be cooking for 20 minutes so i want the
veg to sort of have texture after it's
cooked peppers in
a bit of garlic two nice cloves
just slap down
off with the shell
garlic in
now i want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well
in the center
in
now
start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the skins off and the real flavor of
that
spicy italian sausage is gonna come
through
what's great about this recipe is that
you can use any type of sausage to get
the flavor and the heat you want i've
gone for the spicy italian but it's just
as good with merguez or cheeto
a teaspoon
paprika in give it that really nice
smoky flavor
rice in
and we're gonna sort of basically sear
the rice we call it in the kitchen
blasting the rice where we sort of soda
the rice for 30 seconds and it takes on
all that flavor
next white wine
so the wine sort of deglazes the pan and
washes all that flavor from the bottom
of the pan into the rice
stock in bring it up to the boil turn it
down and let it simmer
[Music]
double stop to rice
turn that gas down
and let it simmer for 12 to 15 minutes
and just give it the occasional stir
keep an eye on it now get ready to
finish it
slice spring onions diced sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf parsley
spring onions in tomatoes in
off with the gas really important
otherwise everything becomes overcooked
flat leaf parsley in
but look
at the volume in that pan now that
is an amazing way to take spicy italian
sausages
to a completely different level
beautiful
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course packed
with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
welcome to my ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on right
this is more ultimate food on a budget
[Music]
vegetables are such an asset in the
kitchen healthy fantastically fresh and
incredibly versatile and pound for pound
they're so much cheaper than fish or
meat just make sure you give them plenty
of attitude
my first recipe is so quick and easy but
seriously impressive and deceptively
cheap
homemade gnocchi
making your enoki is so simple to do yet
the results are absolutely stunning and
it's a great way of using up leftover
baked potatoes
you can make noki just with flour and
eggs however the potato gives it a nice
light sort of creamy fluffy texture cut
them in half take your spoon
and scoop the inside of those potatoes
i'm using leftover baked potatoes but
this really works as well with leftover
ball potatoes two choices you can get a
fork and sort of mash the potato and get
it nice and light and fluffy or
this little gadget it's called a ricer i
suppose it's a posh word
for a potato masher just squeeze gently
you can see how nice and light it is
almost like fluffy little strands of
potato
you can do this when the potatoes are
hot
it'll go through the rice so much
quicker
just slice that off there
now
a nice spoon of okata ring a little
touch of salt and pepper it's really
important to season the mixture as we go
along otherwise the nokia becomes really
bland
flour over the ricotta sieved so there's
no lumps
one delicious egg give that a little
whisk
now
make a little well in the center
you want a nice soft
pliable ball of dough
give that a really good mix
get some thyme flowers in there and this
time is light fragrant and it's just a
really nice herb and with the ricotta
it tastes brilliant just pick the little
tips the time flowers
next flour your hands generously and
knead the mixture into a dough
fold in and push and basically what it's
doing is get it nice and smooth
as it starts to get a little bit wet
and just add a little touch of flour we
want something really nice and soft now
don't overwork it
it stops the nokia from expanding when
it hits the pan
that's exactly what i want a nice sort
of soft
fragrant ball cut the ball in half
lightly flour
the hands and just roll it
gently
just think of a big long cigar
the mixture will start getting a little
bit sort of wetter but do not add lots
of flour
now
lightly flour the knife so when you
slice the gnocchi it doesn't stick
cut the dough into bite-sized pieces
just take your finger dip it in the
flour and push down
why i want my nokia to look like a
pillow
and for me the most important part there
is that not one of them are identically
the same shape
water on
bring up to the boil little touch of
olive oil in there
lightly flour your hand
lift up the
gnocchi in to the rolling boiling water
turn that pan to stop them from sticking
at the bottom and let them simmer and
they start to sort of tell you they're
cooked when they start floating get a
pan on
get that nice and hot now they're just
starting to come up to the top and you
can continue cooking them like that i
like blanching them in the water taking
them out and then frying them to study
the gnocchi heat olive oil in a frying
pan
gently lift up and look
they've doubled in size
drain it get rid of the excess water and
straight in to the hot pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
sauteed texture on the outside
nokia loves fresh pepper
so
pepper in
and see as i start turning them i've got
this really nice little sort of
brown
color
and they're almost popping up now like
little parcels so i want them nice and
sauteed both sides but light
and creamy in the center
fresh garden peas
in
and the butter gives it a really nice
sort of
bernoulli flavor on the end
beautiful
a little bit of fresh thyme over the
peas and then finally i want to lift it
up fresh lemon
zest the lemon over
[Music]
smells incredible
and then finally seal the deal with a
touch of grated parmesan cheese give
your vegetable attitude and you'll get
amazingly elegant dishes on a budget
that are always guaranteed to impress
what more do you want from great cooking
cheap to make easy to cook and
absolutely stunning
cooking great food doesn't mean you have
to spend a fortune on fancy equipment
get some basic essentials and you'll be
set in the kitchen saucepans i mean
basically you don't need a collection of
ten all you need really is two a medium
size one followed by a large one a small
pan is great for sauces heating liquids
or rice whereas your large pan gives you
space perfect for pastas stews or when
you're cooking in bulk which keeps costs
down
made from copper to stainless steel find
what's right for you and always get a
lid which helps heat the pan up as
quickly as possible
and the secret behind a great saucepan
is
the heavier the bottom the more heat it
will conduct the thinner the bottom the
more chance you've got actually burning
your food
buy the best saucepans you can afford
take good care of them and they'll last
you years saving you money in the long
run
amazing recipes don't necessarily have
to include meat cooking vegetarian
dishes will reduce your food bills
without compromising on taste and flavor
here are three more recipes to satisfy
even the keenest carnivore like me that
will max out on veg and won't break the
bang
[Applause]
starting with spicy black beans with
feta and avocado
[Music]
first in a pan heat olive oil add
chopped onion and fry until soft
then finely slice garlic
and chili
add cumin
cinnamon
and black beans then combined
cooked together until deliciously soft
these small beans come dried or in tins
and they're a great cheap ingredient to
make dishes more substantial
to serve dollop the black bean mixture
on crunchy tortillas
topped with cubed ripe avocado chopped
fresh coriander and crumbled salty feta
cheese
spicy black beans with feta an avocado a
dish has filling frugal and tastes
fantastic
my next great veg recipe is
leaking green rusty with fried
[Music]
eggs in a hot pan sweat shredded leeks
along with a knob of butter and
seasoning
next
great parboiled potatoes and grill a
hard swiss cheese with a great nutty
flavor
then combine with the softened leeks
in a pan heat oil and a little butter
spoon in the potato leek and cheese mix
cook gently until golden and crisp
underneath
then slide onto a plate
flip over and return to the pan to
finish cooking
[Music]
finally for the perfect topping fry two
eggs
and place them on top of the rosty
top with fresh tarragon
[Music]
leaking gria rosti with fried eggs a
simple but substantial dish that makes
the most of hearty root veg
addisha takes as much time to write on a
blackboard as it does to cook
chickpea cumin and spinach coffees with
tahini dressing
[Music]
in a blender put tin chickpeas
cumin seeds
paprika
and turmeric
and blitz to a paste
[Music]
next we'll spinach in olive oil and chop
finely then add to the chickpea mixture
sprinkle in gram flour made from finely
ground chickpeas then shape golf
ball-sized chunks of the mixture using a
spoon and rest in the fridge
when ready to cook heat oil in a frying
pan
shallow fry the coppers until golden
brown on all sides
then rest them on kitchen paper to
absorb any excess oil
for an easy dipping sauce mix yogurt
with a dollop of tahini
and a squeeze of lemon
and stir in freshly chopped coriander
a mouth-watering dish that's perfect for
sharing
chickpea cumin and spinach coffees with
tahini dressing
[Music]
three amazing recipes with fantastic veg
proof that even if you're cooking on a
budget you can still eat like a king
incredible welcome back to my ultimate
cookery course
[Music]
this is how to cook amazing food on a
budget
next up my guide to getting the best
ingredients for your money my shopping
mantra is simple first rely on your
senses make sure whatever you're buying
that it looks smells and really feels
good second is to recognize that
knowledge is crucial the more you know
personally about where your ingredients
are from and how they produce the better
so don't be scared ask lots of questions
and learn
[Music]
and when it comes to buying potatoes a
great ingredient if you're cooking on a
budget one green grocer who can always
spot a duds bud is borough market
royalty fred foster it's all about
flavour it's all about
choosing the right variety for the right
dish he's been selling top quality veg
for over 15 years and really knows his
king edwards from his duke of yorks
basically there's two types of potatoes
there's early season
and a main crop potato early season is
basically round about may time you can't
store them they cannot be stored you
have to buy them and use them within two
to three days when you're buying an
early season potato you must avoid green
looking potatoes at all costs it really
is important and the way you can tell
that is if you just brush the potato the
skin comes off really really easy and
then you want you want a yellowy or
whitey looking potato the new seasoned
potato is a superb potato to use
new season types include rocket home
guard and marist bard but my favorite is
the classic jersey royal it has a
delicate sweet flavor it's packed with
vitamin c and is great in salads or
simply boiled and mixed with olive oil
and fresh mint
jersey potatoes early crop are
phenomenal
look at that
keep the skin on it's really important
just wash it boil it it's a beautiful
beautiful potato and that's what we're
talking about we're talking about i know
it's a potato i know it's a bit sad but
we're talking about flavour
right then what is a main crop potato
it's the crop that is grown specifically
for
nine months of the year use when you're
looking at a main crop potato you need
to see that the eyes aren't too large
because they tend to go right through
the potato
they've got to be firm it's very very
important if a potato in any way feels a
little bit soft
discard it storage wise dark place cool
place
dry place and that will last until you
eat it simple as that
both early season and main crop potatoes
come in two main types waxy and flowery
waxy potatoes have a smooth dense flesh
and because they're low in starch they
stay firm when cooked
types include anya and pink fur but i
love charlotte which has an amazing
buttery taste and a great sauteed in
stews or serves whole with roast chicken
flowery potatoes have a fluffy dry
texture when cooked which makes them
great for mashing roasting or cutting
into chips
types include king edward whose smooth
creamy flesh is perfect for potato
gratins or with rich meats like beef and
desiree which have an amazing red skin
and are great for bacon or as delicious
potato wedges
old-fashioned types known as heritage
potatoes are now widely available and
have fantastic colours and distinctive
tastes that are great when you want
something different
this one's called salad blue when you
cut it
you then see
the most amazing color
and it's perfect it looks stunning on
the plate
are really popular
it's so important when you're going out
to pick your potatoes you already know
in advance what you're going to do with
that potato
so whether you're going to put it in a
salad whether it's a masher or a chipper
or even a baking potato each variety has
a unique flavor fred's spot on whether
new season main crop waxy or flowery
potatoes are incredibly versatile and
packed with great flavor the perfect
ingredient when you're cooking on a
budget well how much do i love potatoes
well
cook them simply
proper flavors
it doesn't get any better
[Music]
like all chefs for me there's nothing
better than seasonal produce at its peak
when fruit and veg is fresh in season
and fantastically ripe i can't wait to
get back in the kitchen
to get the most out of your cooking
always use ingredients in their prime
my next recipe is a proper british
classic that's super simple to cook and
cost next to nothing a delicious apple
crumble
crumbles are the perfect way to use
fruit when it's in season there's lots
of it about it's nice and cheap but most
importantly the fruit's at its absolute
best
first off i'm gonna make a really nice
light caramel pan on nice and low great
to apples
[Music]
and this helps to almost sort of puree
the apples so much quicker
there's a lot of flavor in the skin so
don't worry about peeling the fruit
whether it's pears plums peaches
flavors in the skin
nice
to start the caramel a couple of
tablespoons of sugar the sugar helps to
get rid of the tartness in the apple
a touch of cinnamon that starts to make
it a little spicy open up your vanilla
just scrape out all those seeds
now this just makes it light and
fragrant all those seeds
in
to the sugar when making caramel be
patient and always swirl the dish
instead of stirring it
when the sugar goes brown add the apple
that starts to sort of cool down the
caramel
but it gives it a really nice sort of
caramelized puree apple's almost
disintegrating
smells incredible
turn the gas down
slice up two apples
it's a crumble that's got no frills
straight forward no faffing around no
peening of the skin
i want them to sort of stand out from
the caramel
apples in
now those nice thick chunks of apple
sort of almost bedding itself into the
puree
dried cranberries gives it that nice
sort of shock in the texture
sweet
and chewy
i want it to sort of taste zesty spicy
so
sit the lemon zest on top of your apples
and cranberry
fresh lemon juice over and that just
gives that extra acidic kick takes the
cranberries the apples the caramel and
the cinnamon to another level turn the
gas off
so that that sits
and let's concentrate on the crumble
flour in
a couple of tablespoons of demerara
sugar sugar helps to get the topping
nice and crispy
butter in
[Music]
give that a nice little rub what we're
looking for is like a
a bread crumb mixture lightly season it
with a touch of cinnamon
and the demerara sugar sort of helps to
get a nice fine crumble mix and it stops
the butter from sort of melting
in that flour
so that's the basic crumble mix
but i'm not finished yet
muesli
two-thirds crumble
one-third muesli mix that in if you
haven't got muesli then crunchy granola
works brilliantly too lovely
now start off in the center
and work your way around
i want the crispiness on the top
the puree on the bottom of the caramel
and then the texture
in the center a good tip
turn the gas back on i want it bubbling
before it goes in the oven because then
you just got to cook the top so as soon
as you see
that caramel starting to bubble down the
side and she goes
let's go
bake at 200 degrees celsius for 12 to 14
minutes until golden brown
smells amazing
beautiful
still bubbling
[Music]
and look at it
a delicious but very simple crumble with
apples at their absolute best
beautiful
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
first up cooking pasta a great budget
basic to keep in the cupboard it can be
easily undercooked or overcooked here's
how to do it properly first water in
nice large pan to make sure the pasta's
got sufficient room to cook evenly
nicely seasoned absolutely crucial
olive oil in
that stops the pasta from sticking
together
bring it up to the ball
that's the rolling boil the secret there
it stops the pasta from sticking
together and it gently rolls it around
now this is angel pasta nice thin
pasta takes three and a half to four
minutes so into the pan as it hits the
water it melts and then you turn it
round
tongs as that starts to melt gently
twist that into the pan bring it back up
to the boil if you're bad at timing then
set a timer
beautiful
to test it
lift a little strand
and you can actually feel it with your
fingers it's still nice and firm
al dente not a bite not a strong bite
but just really nice and firm inside
definitely not crunchy and then
into a colander drain the pasta
in
a light seasoning
salt
and pepper
a tablespoon
of olive oil
mix that through
that stops it from sticking together
and look
there you go beautiful pasta al dente
and
cooked perfectly
a tip for making the most of spare bread
blitz leftovers into breadcrumbs great
for stuffing or crab cakes or cut into
chunks and freeze for perfect croutons
on demand or simply tear a news in a
delicious rustic salad
dried pulses like chickpeas or lentils
are great for soups and stews and cost
pennies but don't season them until the
end of the cooking or the salt makes
them go tough
for perfect boiled potatoes always start
them off in cold water and never boiling
water this way by the time the centers
of the potatoes are cooked the outside
won't be falling apart
and when you're cooking potatoes always
cook extra so there's leftovers they're
fantastic to have on hand for making my
delicious gnocchi and potato rusties for
a classic bubbling squeak
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course packed
with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
you